i felt worse he said then a moment later
no i haven't but i'm all right how bad
was it you're both dead naomi said
seriously we had to override the triage
filters on both of you more than once
the expert system kept clicking you over
into hospice care and shooting you full
of morphine hey guys pete here in just
over two months the final book in the
expanse series will finally be here and
i'm pretty excited in just over a decade
they've delivered a nine volume tail and
i can't wait to see how it ends to get
ready i'm doing a re-read of the entire
series from the beginning and today i'm
going to talk about why you should read
the books if you haven't done that yet
and some of what you'll get out of it if
you've only watched the show i'm gonna
do that by highlighting the most
interesting changes from book to show
that stood out to me while re-reading
leviathan wakes and since the story gets
to pretty much the same place there's
not really any spoilers here if you've
seen the first couple of seasons
if you're here you've probably watched
my videos about the tv series and you
already know that i encourage everyone
that likes that to read the books i get
asked that question all the time in the
comments of my videos and just to
reiterate you should definitely read the
books if you like these characters if
you like them even a little bit then
you'll get a whole different take on
them when you experience the story
through their points of view a lot of
people ask if you can just skip right to
book six if you want to find out how the
tv show might end and i think that would
be a mistake technically you could get
away with that but you would be confused
by some of the characters and you'll
likely end up going back and starting
from the beginning at some point anyway
it's a situation where the authors of
the book are producers on the show and
they're in the writers room guiding the
story and contributing to the writing of
the episodes which means it is a close
adaptation but it's different enough
that it doesn't feel redundant so
ideally start at the beginning and just
read everything in publication order
including the novellas if you can
because those are awesome and they add a
lot to the main books even though they
are quick reads there isn't a lot of
time left so you might not be able to
make it through all of them by the time
leviathan falls comes out but you'd
likely be able to get caught up with the
show by the time the final season comes
out and then you'd be ready to finish
the story off by reading the final
trilogy i would also say that the audio
books are highly recommended a lot of
times i prefer listening to audiobooks
after i know who the main characters are
and what's going on in a series so
having seen the show makes that really
easy here on top of that jefferson maze
does a fantastic job and his performance
really adds to the experience it's
actually become a big part of the whole
thing for me at this point and i can't
even hold the fact against him that he
had me saying abasarala's name wrong
when i started making videos
as to the why the honest number one
selling point i have for reading the
expanse books is that they're a lot of
fun maybe that seems uninspired or
reductive but it really is my favorite
thing about reading them because they do
a great job of developing the characters
i really enjoy seeing how they react to
the high-stakes situations that they're
always finding themselves in the second
anna leviathan wakes specific selling
point is the character miller you get to
know him so much better in this book and
since his whole art concludes by the end
of it this really is a must read if
you're a miller fan who he is and how he
sees things really does help to flesh
out this world he's a belter he works
for an earth corporation his partner's
an earther there's a lot of extra
details you pick up seeing things
through his eyes and having access to
his thoughts
beyond the fun and the characters the
fact that the imagined near future
setting is believable is a big plus and
while the authors seem to go to great
lengths to try to get things right
scientifically it's never overwhelming
most of the world building happens hand
in hand with the character development
which means you can still follow what's
going on even if you're not absorbing
all the finer points about how
everything works in space
for me i end up caring about the
characters nothing about this time that
they're in seems completely unrealistic
i can imagine it it feels lived in and
the culture and attitudes track with how
the world is now and i know their
tendency towards hard sci-fi is a big
selling point for some i'm okay with it
feeling believable to my non-scientist
mind but there's a lot more that's
spelled out in the books if you're
really trying to wrap your head around
the feasibility of it all compared to
this show the best thing about leviathan
wakes is that there are only two primary
points of view you learn about working
to make a living to get by in the harsh
environment of space and the future crew
of the ross ante through holden's
thoughts and you learn about life in the
belt working on a station that's
controlled by the corporate interests of
the inner planets from millers there's
no earth subplot with abasarala and
aaronright in the first book which means
the focus stays on protogen's actions
leading up to the eros incident and how
these two different characters with
different backgrounds and perspectives
react and how their stories get drawn
together
overall that works a lot better for
setting the table and i think the world
building is more natural and easy to
pick up on i came to the books through
the show i watched it first so i already
knew how things were gonna play out more
or less but in that first season there
was so much going on so many characters
to meet and remember and so many
different locations it was easy to miss
a lot of those world building details
since there's less to keep track of the
book does a better job setting up the
series and what it's about you can see
how colonization is working out for the
belters who wound up being the meat for
the machine it's clear that it's a story
about people and how they're affected by
the various events that take place in
the series including those that are of
extra solar origin the baseline is
exploitation and there's a lot of
potential for things to get worse
and that's a great place to transition
to talking about the changes from book
to show because the changes in the
belters bodies is one of the big things
that the show couldn't pull off in the
beginning of season one they show you a
little bit of what it would look like
but then it's just really not practical
and they start to rely on things like
the way that they dress and their
tattoos to kind of set them apart but a
big part of this whole story is that
these are humans that went out and lived
in low gravity which caused their bodies
to change in a way that you can see that
makes them easy to otherwise to be
thought of as less than human and
historically we know how that turns out
one of the first surprises i had reading
the book was that the beginning is a lot
different for one holden's already the
exo and the future crew of the rossi
know each other already they already get
along once the can is destroyed they
naturally think of holden as the leader
and there's a lot less pushback there's
less conflict altogether the knight is
never damaged because that mostly served
to show how difficult it can get when
things go wrong in space the book can
use holden's internal dialogue to flesh
out the characters and those same
details so you don't have to have that
situation to establish things there are
trade-offs but i mostly prefer the
book's version in most cases just to be
clear though it's a matter of adaptation
from one medium to the other most of the
changes that they made make sense in
that context it's all a way of getting
to the same place relying on what works
for the different mediums i do feel like
they developed alex and amos earlier in
the show and i did like the way that
they handled the doninger a little
better on tv captain yao was a good
addition and the foreshadowing of
naomi's secret past that won't be
revealed until season five is pretty
effective i like that in the book there
was no add a scene that played like a
mystery about what she was gonna say but
it never really goes anywhere in my mind
things do develop better without the
crew drama and by seeing everyone how
holden sees them there's less guessing
about where things are going there's a
mutual respect and a bond that's forged
through the experiences on the cant and
donager
one thing that jumped out to me the
first time i read the book is that
holden is the one that gives fred the
proto-molecule sample he just does it
without much fanfare when he's trying to
buy more time from miller who came up
with the idea of trying to convince
julie not to crash eros into earth the
show deciding to have naomi do that
later on is supposed to show her
complicated feelings as a belter but i
think it just came off as a betrayal to
a lot of viewers and diminished her
character i also thought the
relationship between holden and naomi
plays out better in the book in his
chapters you see his admiration for her
and you can sense that it's leading
somewhere he also reflects on how he's
relied on her resourcefulness and
expertise when they were on the can't he
continues to do that when they get their
own ship and he gets to the point where
he actually feels bad about it as far as
their attraction she lays out her
feelings up front and it feels right
when they get together as i mentioned
you do get to know miller better and i
do think it improves his story i thought
that his obsession with julie made more
sense on an emotional level in the show
he spends a lot more time looking into
her so it doesn't seem out of left field
when it consumes him but i found his
trajectory in the book more relatable
parts of his journey are a lot more
clear the way dawes belittles him saying
that he can't even find out who stole
their riot gear comes to mind and
generally i do like how mysterious dawes
was in the book compared to the show
although i have to say i wouldn't want
to give up the jared harris scenes
either he does a great job with the role
and i think it works pretty well on the
show but he did seem more mysterious and
the opa in general seem more mysterious
in the book there miller feels a little
farther gone to me and there's a moment
when he realizes that his boss and his
co-workers all look at him like a washed
up hack he internalizes that and
generally accepts that they're right but
you see through his actions of being a
pretty good detective and figuring
things out that he's not entirely right
and there's something that really works
to close out his story in that book
miller went to eros never intending to
come back he's basically suicidal at
that point and he's okay with going
there and ending his life
and those are the main things for me as
mentioned i watched the show first so i
went into the book with the characters
and events already in my head and it was
fascinating to think about how they
adapted the story for the screen some
changes work better than others but they
all mostly make sense holden and miller
are the perfect povs to start out with
the way that they see things the way
that they experience things it's really
a nice setup for when their stories come
together i also like that the book opens
and closes with two earthers that are
fully on board with supporting the opa
getting into the heads of julie and fred
and their povs is a good way to open and
close things i think the first season is
good but i think there were a lot of
difficulties baked in as far as
presenting the world building it took a
while for me to get into it initially i
wasn't sold on the series until i really
started digging the characters and
thinking of the crew in that found
family kind of way there was a lot to
keep track of on the first time through
and on re-watch so many more of the
details pop out when you already know
what's going to happen and i think
reading the book gives the same kind of
experience i highly recommend it and i
think that's a good place to leave
things let me know in the comments how
you compare the books to the show what
changes did you like which ones didn't
you like and anything else that jumped
out at you i'll be rereading them all
before leviathan falls comes out so let
me know if you want to see more videos
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and thanks for watching
i'll talk to you soon